if a famous golfer wasn't interested in politics a
famous Walker definitely was president by accident
Harry Truman was out to win the office on his
own and some folks were saying he hadn't done too
badly for a beginner he laid down the law on that
coal strike didn't he and the Marshall Plan jolted
the Russians all right but still had been a lot
of bundling and government by crony and didn't the
Republicans sweep the last congressional elections
with a slogan had enough all the political experts
were saying the country had had enough and Harry
didn't have a prayer but he's from Missouri had
to show him the Republicans were happy to
oblige the sweet scent of victory was in the
air at the 48th Convention in Philadelphia we're
confident party leaders gathered a name there man
delegates had that choice of several GOP
stalwarts including Robert a Taft of Ohio
the keynoter called Harry Truman
a gone goose the opinion polls all
predict Ulis smashing Republican victory and
everybody was sure that the next president
United States was being picked right here
governor Thomas Edmund Dewey in New York
then the Democrats convene in Philadelphia to
and newspapers reported quote an era of gloom
and despondency and the colonists were writing
quote every season Democratic leaders convinced
that Harry Truman will suffer a historic defeat
the Liberals were against him the Dixiecrats
walked out of it and the big city bosses thought
the whole thing was hopeless but it had to be
Harry who else so the convention went through
the motions and Harry Truman was nominated
the ticket was Truman and alben Barkley and Harry
evidently didn't read the papers he thought he
was gonna win and one reporter called him quote
battling Harry the demon necktie salesman he's
got more guts than a fiddle string Factory but
Harry wasn't listening he was off and rolling
on a whistle-stop campaign that took him across
22,000 miles and threw 270 speeches governor do
he did read the papers they were all saying the
same thing he couldn't lose across the country
a Republican tide was rolling according
to the pollsters and one shrewd analyst
was predicting the Dewey would be in the White
House not for just four years but eight years
Harry Porter now with old-style grass announced
all Republicans back to but not including Abraham
Lincoln and he never left the governor
delivered dignified high-minded speeches
and never even mentioned his opponents
name across the country that people came
and listened and what they were thinking they
kept to themselves the political writers have
no doubts fifty of them were polled during
the campaign and they all picked do it
mighty gay moose proper people said too bad he
doesn't have a chance and the New York Times
was saying quote Thomas e Dewey's election as
president United States is a foregone conclusion